I'm thinking about my mum and my dad and
how they would be so happy and proud and
whatever because we all want to please
our mums and dads don't we and um you
know it was a long road for me I
displeased them for some of my life
um so I think they'd be happy that I
landed up in this place but the other
thing I'm feeling very strongly is that
this is a kind of challenge it's taking
me to a new place and it's it's a kind
of commission I think that's the way I
regard it to do good in the world and do
better than I've done before
I'm from Rockstar to Lioness four
England women footballers on the Euro
2022 Winning Side have been recognized
and made mbes one of them Lucy bronze it
recognizes all of the achievements put
together and says
yeah you've achieved so much both as an
individual and the team that you've
played in as a person
as a footballer
um and we recognize that and want to
celebrate your success and I guess
that's the way I see it is celebrating
everything together so I guess it goes
right to the top
England women's Coach Serena vegman's
also been given an order of the British
Empire
and another sporting Hero 2 Olympic gold
medalist Denise Lewis made a Dame it's
22 years ago since I won that gold medal
in in Sydney and uh so to be receiving
an Accolade as big as this
um it's almost more the sweeter because
it isn't for my single performance it's
it's for service to the sport that has
given me so much
um it might be my life
among politicians honored Labor's Chris
Bryant Commons standards committee chair
will receive a Knighthood I just know so
many people in the Rhonda who deserve
this so much more than I do nurses
carers you know posties bus drivers and
so on let alone other MPS which is a bit
more than I do so I was really really
shocked but most of the more than 1 000
recipients are lesser known like clean
air campaigner Rosamund whose
nine-year-old daughter Ella died from an
asthma attack and air pollution in 2013.
you know when Sadiq Khan keeps on saying
to me you're saving lives yes I know but
I I want especially with asthma I want
children to stop dying because I know in
Scandinavian countries children don't
really die from Mass and that and that's
really what I want for children in this
country
an honors list that nods to some highs
and lows of recent years celebrating
both sung and unsung heroes Adele
Robinson Sky News